Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Active Flab Stream
number 18.1.
We're here with Julian Epstein.
And Michael Kirchhoff, as well as Dave
Dean and Steven from Acton Lab.
And we're really appreciative
for the authors for joining today.
To be discussing some of their work.
We're going to have a presentation
by the authors.
And then following the presentation,
we'll have ample time for discussion.
So please feel free to write
any questions down in the live chat
and we'll get to it.
So without further ado,
Julian and Michael,
thanks a lot for joining
and please take it away.
Well, thanks so much for inviting us.
We've been looking forward
to this particular session
and thanks for staying up late in the US
and where we are in Europe
for getting up early.
It's only 330 in the afternoon here
for us, so
that's more manageable in Australia.
I'll just share my screen
share
so that
you guys can see that.
Bring that up
So that should all be clear in a second.
Is that right? Looks good. Great.
So the paper is called the Literalness
Fallacy and the Free Energy Principle.
It's a it's a philosophical paper
on the topic of scientific realism.
Scientific entropy is much less
instrumentalist in the context of the ATP
or the free energy principle,
I suppose, just as a primer.
This is a revise
and resubmit stage for our paper.
This particular moment in time.
So any comments that we might be able
to get to further
improve the quality of the paper will,
of course, be
welcomed
So let's let's start.
There will be a little bit of, I suppose,
conceptual stage setting at the start,
just given the nature
of this particular paper.
And also because it sort of speaks
to a few other issues that go beyond
just the sort of narrow
focus on the free energy principle
So this is
the debate as it sits, or at least
as we try to sketch it in the paper
between scientific realism
and instrumentalist.
So let's just say briefly
what scientific realism is and briefly
what instrumentalist means,
and then we'll say a little bit more
about how to think about scientific
realism overall.
The point of the paper was to sort of
try to marshal
a set of arguments for why
at least a version of scientific realism
can be accommodated by models.
And it was motivated in part
because it seems like
in the last few years that's been the
there's been a flurry of papers
sort of in one way or another arguing
for scientific anti realism with respect
to the CPE or how to interpret parts
of that particular model.
So that's the kind of that's
the kind of setting we're in.
So scientific realism, that's the view
that one reasonable goal for currently
best scientific theories, scientific
models, is to offer literally true
or probably true or approximate and true
or probably approximately true
descriptions
and explanations of target systems.
Have you in brackets,
for example, natural phenomena
but it could also be artificial systems
in the context
of artificial intelligence,
artificial life, for example.
Now, by contrast, an
instrumental issue or scientific realism,
that's the view that scientific theories
and models are nothing but instruments
for prediction of observable
behavior of target systems.
So here the claim is something like this
from an instrumentalist
perspective theory slash models.
They have explanatory power
and that gives them some utility,
but they're not in any in
any sense of the word truth producing.
So when it's not to think about
instrumentalists
or the instrumental position
as putting forth statements
about how the world
is on the basis of their models,
by which you can say something,
say true or false about how
the world is
So the main question now
is for this particular paper
we are considering,
is the truth producing in a way that's
consistent with scientific realism.
And of
course, as I mentioned
just a minute or so ago, we think it is
indeed consistent with a particular way
of conceiving of scientific realism.
And maybe a footnote here
that's important,
both scientific realism and instrumental.
Quite okay.
A multiple there's multiple different
versions of each particular
framework in the philosophy of science
that we're trying to offer
a reasonable general characterization
of these particular frameworks
in order to sort of
get some traction on the debate
So as I said, it's a reasonable goal
of our scientific theories and models
to apply these true will probably
to approximate true
descriptions of target systems
Now, here we we we draw inspiration
from Peter Godfrey-smith.
His book here is in reality
that tells us how
perhaps to interpret
that particular general claim.
Now, he says the following
he says it's mistake to express
the scientific situation
in a way that depends
on the accuracy
of our current scientific theories.
So if we express
scientific realism by asserting
the real existence of entities
recognized by science
at this particular point in time,
then if those particular theories
turn out to be false,
well then the whole framework of
scientific realism turn out to be false.
So we shouldn't think that's
what you have to do in order to advocate
for a kind of scientific realism
about scientific models, theories
and their relation to target systems
So building on this, we can say
again, this notion here
is that an actual and reasonable
aim of science is to give us
these accurate descriptions.
Well, that's not the claim.
The scientific
theories must be true. Now,
and make truth
producing claims about targets.
Now, I mean, it's a nice thing if they
do, but it is not a necessary condition
for the one to adopt scientific realism,
not scientific theories, models.
There's no commitment to the success
of the individual sciences.
So there can be trouble in biology
but we can still hold, for instance,
scientific realism about, for instance,
the applied
to the cognitive sciences, for example.
Now, importantly, and this is
and this is why I'm just spending
a little bit of time
initially on scientific realism
the kind of version of scientific
realism we're interested in
is going to allow for theories and models
to posit idealized nations.
For instance, understood
as distortions, approximations,
understood here as perhaps in exactness
of scientific models
they can pose a fictional entity,
for instance, entities
that are not actual
and thus like in the here and now.
But the important point is
that you can keep
that view
and still endorse scientific realism,
because one aspect here
is that the long term aim
of working with
your scientific models is for them
to become to producing or to become more
and more aligned with the target systems
that we're interested in.
And we'll finish this view
as we sort of move along
Now, this issue
between the scientific realist
and the instrumentalist as that's
considering it in the context of the key
it comes up
when we consider
what we call the map problem.
And this is not a term of art
that we have invented
or the sort of authors in the both
in the AFP and elsewhere
that make use of this.
For instance, Mil Andrews
in her nice paper from 2021 in biology
and philosophy
that speaks of this particular problem
So this is just a quote from the paper
thinking about what our focus is.
So we're going to ask
what is the relationship between
scientific models
constructing using the body
and the realities
these models purport to represent?
My focus is especially on the sea
and what,
if anything, it tells us about the system
that is used to model.
And this is what we call the map problem.
How does the map, your theories,
your models relate to the territory?
Real world
target systems of which those theories
and models are maps
Now, if there's anybody
joining on the livestream,
this is just a very brief statement about
what the free energy principle says.
Julian and I and as well as Ian,
are working under the assumption
that that doesn't need to take long to introduce that in this particular context.
But very briefly then
states that are self-organizing system
that tends towards maintaining
an equilibrium and steady state for this
environment must minimize free energy
where minimizing free energy,
at least under a certain Bayesian
interpretation, is to maximize
model evidence, that is, maximize
the likelihood of some data given
even model of the systems interactions
with its environment.
Now, how does the problem arise
in the context of the ATP?
Well, it might arise if you're a
researcher working
in artificial intelligence, and the aim
is to build robots that engage
in active inference for example,
navigating or making decisions, cetera.
So here the question becomes
what's the relationship
between our EP model understood
as an active inference model?
And then how one engineered is,
if you like,
artificial agents to perform in
accordance with those particular models.
What the model specifies in terms
of, say, decision making
belief, updating and selecting action
policies for adaptive.
Pavia
a different way than that
problem might arise
would be from the computational
neuroscientific perspective,
where one might be interested in tracking
transitions across belief,
perhaps in deep
generative models.
And the problem then is, well,
how does that
you reticle specification of free energy
minimization under active inference?
How does that move on to
what the brain actually does
in order to say, shift
from beliefs to beliefs
or to make decisions
about what to do in the world?
So that's just a few examples of where
this particular issue becomes
pervaded.
Now, just to situate this discussion
a little bit,
because there's a few tweaks
and turns in the paper and it's a large,
somewhat complex
conceptual landscape we're working on.
But it seems to me
we're just going to
try to situate this a little bit more
so you get a feel for this.
We've got a nice review, a comment
that sort of introduces the issue here.
So the comment is something like
if we take the free energy
principle, like
many other theories
across different sciences,
then we can think about that as a kind
of model based approach to science.
And if you look at the little image
over here, which is a modification of is
sort of a little description
of how this works, modified
by Godfrey-smith in the 2009 paper,
we can initially start
to develop a description of a model
and say something about what
the model system
in question is
and the comment is something like this.
We can study models for their own sake,
as Andrew's has pointed out.
No, that's so true earlier.
Any model that can be treated
realistically can also be treated
instruments and scientists can disagree
about which the model I meant to be real.
Now, this is important in understanding
how the that problem arises.
So Andrew's in the 2021 paper
gives us a whole list of different ways.
One can see the kind
of mathematical structure of the machine
being interpreted as a scientific model.
The work of Michael Weisberg
is influential
in the context of philosophy of science,
philosophy of biology.
So she and
he, they can give sort of minimally three
different models that we're interested in
at the essay sort of target.
Let's model
the ATP as a generalized model and then
is a target directed model.
Now you can work
purely on the mathematics,
if you like, of the free energy principle
for the sake of
just understanding the model
for getting your model description right.
Of your model system as per that image.
Now here,
the point is that that in and of itself
doesn't give rise to anything
like the math problem
because you can disagree,
you can come at that
that work
from an instrumentalist perspective,
you can come at it
from a scientific realist perspective.
But doing that kind of work
doesn't really allow you
to adjudicate between the two positions
or so it seems to us.
So that would be the instance of a target
less model.
You're not asking questions that relate
from the model to a target system.
You can treat the AP
as a generalized model.
You can
perhaps think of it as super model.
Theories with natural selection
from the point of view of the.
But we are not saying anything
about development of any particular
kind of species.
That's one to, for instance,
a different discussion as well,
which we consider
but we won't talk to unless it comes up.
In the Q&A about the role of the mock up
blanket notation.
Now, if we put it in the paper,
that gives you a kind of
generalized approach
for delineating boundaries,
but it doesn't give you a approach
for delineating boundaries
for any particular individual.
In that sense, it's a generalist take
on models on the basis of the formulas
now the math problem
gets interesting
when you pursue a target directed model,
when you try to implement
the mathematical structures positive
by the effective in terms of a process
theory such as act of inference.
So you sort of moving
from a mathematically general
characterization of the adaptive behavior
to specifying
what a particular individual
or a set of individuals must do
in order to engage adaptive in the world.
So you're sort of committing yourself to
and to to getting the sort
of the right hand side of this this model
or this little image, if you like,
saying something about which way
do you model now resemble the systems
that you actually are aiming to explain
or understand
something about OK,
so we should say once we have that,
we should give the argument
for the instrumentalists.
And then once we've done that, we'll see
the kind of problem that we raise
for the instrumentalists that we think
it's a kind of a fallacy of inference
from certain considerations
to certain claims about the
so premise.
One here is that active inference
models on the CFP introduce distortions
in representing biological
and cognitive systems
via idealization.
So one way to think about that
might be the introduction of variation
or free energy as a kind of distortion
into the framework
in order to explore, in order to solve
a computational problem
about how surprising it's minimized
as well as in acceptance approximately.
And one example might be something like
introducing this idea that three energy
minimization can be construed
mathematically as akin to a kind of
Bayesian inference
would be in in exactness
introduced into the formalism
primarily because it was
so it seems nobody thinks that the brain
quite literally
encodes something like Bayes Theorem
OK, and it's to
that is that scientific realism requires
that models provide descriptions
of target systems that are literally true
so that's a somewhat of a denial,
if you like,
if you would, a whole scientific realism
perspective, premise one,
premise three then is that active
inference models are not true
an accurate representation of biological
and cognitive systems
precisely because of the issues
raised in premise one.
Therefore, active inference models false.
There are best useful fictions.
And just to give you
the references
where we are drawing work from in terms
of defining the term idealization
and the term approximation.
Here, we're using a nice paper
by McMullen on Galileo,
an idea that I say
wants to think about idealization,
and we are using a canonical paper
by Naughton to define approximation of
these somewhat contentious mean
because there's,
as one might expect,
there's all kinds of other takes on it,
but you have
to come down on 11 side post.
So once we
have the instrumentalist claim up
and running, this is the kind of fallacy
that we're arguing
that a set of set of papers
defending instrumentalist
in the context of the effect he is making
and we pointed to this for this fallacy
and just the prime use of
premise two here is the claim that
scientific realism requires that models
provide descriptions of target systems
that are literally true.
And it's the claim, the literature,
this fallacy, because we're going to show
that's that that's not a necessary
condition upon which to base one's
defense
of scientific realism.
So what we say is the mistake,
the literalist fallacy
is the mistake of accepting or affirming,
apart
from the fact
that act of inference model,
not literally mapped on to biological
and cognitive systems,
it's slightly different formulation
that we have here
is that in this context of the P,
some find the discrepancy between the map
and the territory a compelling reason
to defend instruments.
It isn't about the P,
and we take that to be problematic.
Given this particular kind of fallacy.
We identify this particular fallacy
by those defending instrumentalists.
We call it the this one is fallacy.
Here's this the second variation of it,
if you like.
This is the fallacy
of inserting the truth of instruments.
It isn't based on the claim
that the properties, if you p models
do not literally map onto real world
target systems.
So so one question that might be
interesting to discuss in the Q&A
is whether or not this is indeed
the problem for a instrumentalist
to infer the truth of their own position
on the basis of the claim
that the properties of their models
do not map literally map
onto real world target systems
so the pushback here on the
second formulation is something like this
instrumentalist and others
searching the truth of their own position
that will be so contradictory
now, this is sort of conceptual issues
here,
but I just wanted to flag the issue
and perhaps come back to it in the Q&A.
It would take us too long to get into it.
And they did some more philosophical,
conceptual
ism, ism evidence, if you like,
set of papers
across some different topics that
we were arguing or committing this.
This kind of fallacy
is a 2020 paper by Venice.
And so that's great.
They say that it remains quote
it remains disputed
whether it's the statistical models
of scientific tools
to describe non equilibrium
steady state systems
which we call the instruments of this
meaning
or necessarily implemented
and utilized by those systems.
The so-called realist reading
know what they're going to conclude
is that since P models are not true
and accurate descriptions
of these target systems instrumented
as it turns out to be the only option.
So for us that's a
that's the nature of this fallacy
because it assumes that the real position
is that your theoretical models
literally have to be implemented
in target systems
for that kind of framework in the philosophy of science to be up and running
within
about 20, 21 because we only updated
20, 22 at some point
this year in the Target article and Bob's
focus on the logical status
of the Markov blanket formula,
some in the SNP.
Now they argue
that much of the literature
on the implies
that organisms literally instantiate
the mathematical structure of Markov
monkeys.
They argue that the use of the formalism
conflicts
a model with its target system.
Now if you think that in order
to use the Markov
rank and formalism productively,
even from the scientific point of view,
that the mathematical formulation
of that particular formalism
has to be implemented
in the actual target system,
then you are committing
the literalist fallacy
because even the scientific view
this is going to push back against that
so Columbo and police use
in a 2021 article in biology
and philosophy target the issue of
this city in the city namely
that one can realistically model
biological systems
as having an exotic density.
Now they deny that this city captures
properties of biological systems
and therefore the effect
is biologically implausible.
And our line on that is that's, that's
akin or species of literalist fantasy
precisely because it's going to assume
that the theorists
actually think that it's part
and parcel of target systems
that they have and ergo
the density I'll take on it is no.
That particular approach
to modeling state transitions
and under DFP is precisely
that it's a kind of
its approach to the sort of it's
an approximation
with more scientific convenience
in order to say
something about how systems
occupy states over time.
But you shouldn't conflate
that particular perspective
with saying that's
naturally the case of target systems.
I'll skip
the last quote here just for time
considerations.
We can come back to this
if there's any issues.
OK, so let's turn with some examples
and some cases of this.
It's really a fallacy in
how to how to think about it.
And in terms of scientific realism,
though, in the paper we consider a bunch
of this sort of cases or examples.
We consider the notion of variation
of free energy.
We consider the Markov blanket formalism,
we consider
the role of Bayesian inference
in these sorts of formulations.
And then finally
we turn to consider the topic of obesity
for this particular presentation,
if you like.
We're only going to focus on
the first variation free energy,
and then the latter,
this is you, and perhaps we can come back
to the other cases in Q&A
OK, it strikes
us there's two different ways
of interpreting
the variation of free energy notation
primed here on the big consideration
that it seems as
if organisms are minimizing variation
of free energy in the long run.
So the formulation here would seems
however pervasive now in the literature,
is not, I think, a one way street.
This is a couple of options here
that we now
want to try to unpack, especially
because we're doing the presentation
and especially because
we've been prompted to do so,
I think by by a set of review comments.
But let's get into it.
This is the sort of first option,
if you like.
That's going to it's going to deliver
a set of reasons for thinking
that instrumental ism was the case.
And we're going
to push back on those particular reasons
so variation of free energy
is an information theoretic construction
used to compute how organisms
are able to resist decay by positing
variation of free energy.
Now, under the ATP,
for an organism to exist,
it must keep its states
within certain bounds.
OK, so that's the generic opener.
So I'll give you some examples now of the
IF formulation
sort of prompted
by this quote from fish then
is a mathematical formulation
of how the systems
to decay rem state and colleagues
to say this means the internal
and active states will look as if they're
trying to minimize the same quantity,
namely the surprise rule of states.
It constitutes the thing,
a particle or some creature.
So here we have the se
if statement they appear to perform
this this kind of minimization
of variation of free energy.
Similarly, in a 2019 paper and
any system that avoids
surprising exchanges
with the world will look as if it's
predicting, tracking and minimizing
the quantity called variation
or free energy on average and over time.
Now I've included this
because we're going to speak to this one,
this particular paper as a second option
for how to think of the acid formulation
and how perhaps the square acid
formulations with a kind of scientific
realism.
Venice 2020
the system does not actually predict
and so will minimize
the quantity called variation of energy.
But it really it looks as
if the probabilistic model merely tracks
certain real statistical relations
in the organism environment system.
So this particular reading here
is first meeting
the formulation of variation
free energy needs to scientific realism
about active inference
models under the P,
and it does so precisely
because we have to sort of treat systems
only as if we're actually minimizing
this particular quantity.
I can
just jump in on this a minute.
So the Rammstein quotes there
saying that what it looks
as if the system is
minimizing is surprising,
whereas von s it's to talking
about variation of free energy.
A good point.
So yeah, I think we could accept that.
It looks as if the system is minimizing
surprise.
All looks variation or free energy.
Is this bound on surprise? Well, yes.
So the round so quotes are actually
consistent with realism. Yes.
They could be read as allowing that
the system really does
minimize variation of the energy
and it looks as if in doing
so it's minimizing surprise or
perhaps we can come back to that
in the discussion
that Ramstad and colleagues are
necessarily
best read as endorsing instrumental ism
and I think
it's quite consistent
with realism, actually.
Yeah, no, I agree.
And I think we'll see that come out
recently explicitly.
We turn to the second option to step in.
If I don't if I don't actually manage
to pull that out explicitly.
Very good. Yeah.
So basically what we can now assume
is that variation of three energy on
this first reading
is a mathematical fiction.
At least that's what we're told.
These sorts of constructs
are useful fictions,
but they don't actually exist.
So how to think about that?
Because we, we tend to agree
with that particular point.
So you can think that variation
of three energy,
a bit like a Galilean frictionless plane,
for example, is a concrete entity
that has some mathematical concreteness
about it,
but it's not one
that actually exists in the system here.
The mass is not that territory.
So even though we can,
we can we can kind of think
of frictionless planes as being concrete
in one sort of sense of it's
mathematical concreteness
one wouldn't want to infer that that
Julian is a friction plane, for example,
that that would be, that would be false
and it would all to me.
And but in the bad sort of inferences
Now, here again,
we draw on the work of Gotham
Smith in order
to think sort of more generally
about the use of fictional entities
in the context of science more generally.
Here's what he says.
Generally speaking, he doesn't address
anything to do with the AFP.
Just to make that clear.
Now, fictions do not exist,
he says, but at least many of them
might have existed, and if they had,
they would have been concrete,
physical things located in space and time
and engaging in causal relations.
So that's kind of counterfactual test.
You can run on fictional entities
and science
from the point of view given you
now you can say fictional entities
such as variation or free energy
that might lack actual existence
and target systems
can be useful for understanding
target systems nevertheless.
So you might say that
active inference models
provide insight into the workings
of biological systems, for instance,
would help helping to understand
what a system has to do
in order to maintain homeostasis.
You can also say something
like the following, namely
that under a kind of patient
interpretation
of how one minimizes
this particular quantity,
you can draw some similarities
to how that so how to price
is minimized in actual target systems
by understanding something
about the minimization
of variation of free energy.
So there's a kind of similarity relation
one can draw between the positive
or fictional entities
in the theoretical models
and then what actual
target systems are doing
now, just to give you a
sense of it so motivated by active
inference models on the day
he time colleagues say the following
about the significance of their work
on active inference.
I'll just give you the quote
and you can kind of see this.
This is coming in to
to to being very brief
we use Magnetoencephalography
Graphy in combination with eye
tracking to assess the neural correlates
of form of short term memory
doing a cancelation task using dynamic
modeling to quantify changes
in effective connect connectivity,
we found evidence that the coupling
between the dorsal and ventral retention
networks change during this interrogation
of a simple visual scene.
Now, they say here
and I've highlighted this intuitively,
this is consistent with the idea
that these neuronal connections
may encode beliefs about what
I would see if I were sort of there
and that this mapping is optimized,
this new data obtained with each fixation
so the idea here
is that fictional entities
such as variation or free energy
allows for a further understanding
of target systems by making precise
how target systems
may minimize free energy, whether or not
that be variation for energy or
expected free
energy
in the sense of minimizing this appraisal
and not directly in the sense
of minimizing these two notations
so the summary here
that we give in the article
is that the F comprises
what is known as indirect representation
of the target system.
So it says something indirectly
about the operations of target systems,
even if it involves the use of abstract
entities.
It's an idealized approach,
sensing complex
or unknown processes in the world.
It's standard practice
to view scientific models
as indirect representations
of the real world target system.
Now, furthermore, most theoretical models
are composed of a set of mixed claims.
Now this is going
this is rather important for us
to sort of preserve
a notion of scientific realism
about the FDP, basically,
and we use the work of Spieler here.
This means that the model will posit,
if true, the presence of what
he calls both OK entity such as electrons
and their ilk
and supposedly non OK entities
such as numbers or theoretical ideals.
And we think this is something
like such a model.
So a model post or composed of mixed
claims,
it put forward all kinds of OK entities,
neurons, reflex acts, et cetera,
and perhaps what you might think of
as not OK
in such as the variation
or free energy notation
where non OK entities
has to be understood in terms
of not being literally
true of their target systems.
So this gets us to the second
formulation that Julien alludes
to, alluded to earlier of the S.F.
formulation.
Now, take us an example here
from Dan, it's 1996, both kinds of minds
and I think
thanks to an anonymous review here
for pointing this to this this idea
then it's so called Iberian creatures.
Now these creatures said to be able
to select from possible action policies,
although it's not put exactly in those
in those terms
in order to prune away inferior options
to avoid fatal consequences.
So in this sense these features
have some kind of in an environment
where they can select
among possible actions.
Now here's the tails of two densities
paper
that I coauthored with Max Ramstad in
and and
I'm not going to read you the quote here,
but the basic idea is going to be
something like this
that one can prune away unwanted action
policies by testing what kind of expected
sensory observations
one might encounter were one to elicit
certain kinds of actions.
But whether or
not one pulls away action,
all of this crucial part here
is that that kind of the least transition
if you will, of possible
sensory outcomes,
given certain kinds of actions,
can itself
be characterized in the fictional way
in a in a form of factionalism,
as Julia mentioned earlier,
that is entirely consistent
as far as we can tell.
And with scientific realism
so for the proper reason,
active inference feature, one can think
of trajectories pursued of a possible
action policies in terms of fictions,
as I just mentioned.
Now we come back to our formulations
of fictional entities in science
from the previous couple of slides ago
now you might say that action
policies are concrete belief states,
but they're not actual.
They do not actually exist.
Given that counterfactual,
hypothetical character
yet, were they to exist, they
would be actual with some causal powers,
there would be implications
for inferring one over the other
arguably some of the hypothesis
come to fruition and therefore exist
so what we have here is an
if formulation of the of FP explanations
that has a fictional characteristic
to it.
So part of the entities
that compose our explanations,
fictional entities,
but they're entirely consistent with
scientific realism about explanations
given the considerations
about the status of fictional entities
and science in general.
OK, so let's see, we've been going
for about 35 minutes, so start wrapping
this up so we can get to the Q&A.
Second case, one slide really quickly
about basically just,
just to get us thinking about this,
at least we can come back to it now
first and define
the circle DCT in the following way.
One can interpret
the average amount of time
a state is occupied as the probability
of a system being in that state
when it's observed at random. OK,
now Colombo and Palacios in this 20, 21
paper in biology and philosophy, they say
that they spaces of biological systems
are structurally unstable.
They're always changing
and unpredictable, unpredictable
making them non ergodic
there isn't a set of fixed states,
if you like, that
the system keeps returning to
if such a system is a biological system
on this particular account
by Colombian corrections.
Now they say that the FSP trades off
realism
for generality and mathematical precision
and they do so in a sense
to sort of put pressure on this idea
that the FSB can be
thought of in terms that are consistent
with scientific realism.
And it's true if you have you take a
the approach to the
as a generalized strategy to modeling
that the traits of realism for generality
and in the same time
maximizing mathematical precision.
But I think here's here's the twist
so this would be the first way
of responding to this particular claim.
If you turn the
p the mathematical structure
into a target directed system,
what we get here,
we get to work with specific systems.
So now you get to increase
the level of realism in your
in the relationship, if you like, between
your model and your target.
System.
A second way of thinking about this city
is that, yeah, OK, it's true
that they don't
they don't have biological plausibility
but you can think of this
as a convenient modeling assumption.
So the AFP doesn't claim that
biological systems are literally a gold
that's even a loosening in the literature
now to say locally ago
or there's even a further loosening.
So shifting to work with this city
entirely
to talk about commonness densities
and so on, where you can actually
still retain this kind of message,
stability, this level of change
and this degree of predictability
so to conclude,
arguments for instrumentalist
about the CEP, or at least
the ones that we are considering.
And so there's one or two.
We have not considered
trade on the Literalness fallacy.
They accept or affirm instrumentalist
on the grounds that the properties
of act of inference models under the AFP
do not literally map
onto biological systems
if we are correct,
then the subversion of scientific realism
that is alive and tenable option
with respect to the awesome.
Thank you.
OK, great times
perhaps for the first word,
we'll go to Julian.
Just feel free to maybe say hi,
give your first take and then we'll go
to the Acton Flap participants.
Yes. So thanks for having us.
It's going to be fun
to talk about this paper and
I think we should just jump straight
into the discussion rather than me.
Add anything onto what
Michael already said.
You gave an excellent
summary of the paper,
so let's see what you guys make of it.
OK, so age or beauty?
Where do we begin
Dave or Dean or Stephen?
Who would like to go first?
Stephen first, then either Dave or.
Well, I'd just like to say
thanks for the book
that you've published a few years ago,
about the Third Wave.
It was actually the key book
that kind of made me keep going
back to infants
after I first heard about it, because
it was a really, really cool,
nice to hear boundaries
because I've been looking at an active,
embodied approaches
and so that's the first piece.
And so in there
you talk about the idea of of blankets.
You're not dying, but the idea of things
being dynamic and changing.
And I'm curious
whether when you're thinking
about instrumentalists
and there's a there's a
there's some ways
that the danger of instruments isn't
is it starts to
everything gets referred back to math
and then the math isn't totally wrong
it's because it's instrumental.
And you of
it can be a kind of a challenge then
where you're trying to bring in the 40.